Research in education differs from
research in other areas in a number of
ways, so I'm going to talk
about two of them here.
One of those ways is the difficulty we
have controlling all the variables at
play in educational research.
We have interactions amongst students,
amongst students and teachers,
amongst the classroom,
amongst the broader school culture, and
we can't control for
all of those things.
So one of our difficulties is
in understanding the full range
of different variables and
dynamics at play.
Another interesting thing in educational
research is that very often we're not
just interested in understanding
learning or understanding education.
I think most of us get into this
field because we want to improve it.
That we want to help
students learn better.
And so when you're sitting in
a classroom observing something and
you recognize a reason why a student's
having trouble learning some material,
it's very difficult not to intervene and
help them because that's
why we're doing this.
And yet, if our main goal
is to understand learning,
then we can't do that.
So for these reasons among others,
a field exists especially in educational
research, although it exists elsewhere
as well, called design-based research.
Design-based research is the idea
of creating something, and
then using that something,
that tool, that protocol,
that behavior, as a probe into classroom
interaction, or the learning process.
What we do here is effectively
build a tool that would work,
if our theory of learning is accurate.
For example, if we're interested
in individualized feedback.
If we believe that students learn
better from individualized feedback,
we would create a tool that uses
individualized feedback, or
gives students individualized feedback.
And then based on whether or not that
tool actually improves learning,
we would reflect back
on our original theory.
If the tool gives students
individualized feedback and they don't
improve in their understanding of some
material, then we might reflect and
say that theory that I used to
justify that tool was actually false.
I don't have any evidence to defend
the idea that that's useful.
But then if that tool actually
does work, we would say,
because I developed a tool that
improved individualized feedback and
because students learned as a result,
my theory about individualized feedback
helping learning must be accurate.
So in designed-based research, we're
designing tools, then using those tools
as probes into the phenomenon that
those tools are designed to address.